ça c'est un bon jeu sérieusement c'est
pas difficile de faire des bourgs jeu et
moi j'aime les bons jeux là je suis en
train de vous montrer un exemple de bons
jeux pour une fois prenez power rangers
the movies sur megadrive par exemple que
demander de plus les graphismes sont
corrects pour la megadrive le jeu n'est
ni trop dur ni trop facile on progresse
à travers les livres on tue ans qui
arrive comme street à fred et on s'amuse
pas besoin de super graphismes en 3d
pour faire un bon jeu et moi j'aime les
beaux jeux qu'elle est celui-là
[Musique]
thq vous vous dites que ça peut pas être
un mauvais jeu parce qu'ils ont fait
suprême commandeur ou warhammer 40000
stalker company of heroes souvenez vous
que c'est electronic arts qui a vomi
dark castle
vous vous souvenez de cette période un
peu charnière dans l'histoire du jeu
vidéo qui a marqué la freine la deux dès
le début de la 3d il y en a qui ont
parfaitement réussi la transition est
bien négocié le virage je pense à
ocarina of time et goldman par exemple
d'ailleurs j'ai acheté 1 nintendo stream
cas que pour ces deux jeux d'ailleurs et
y en a d'autres qui ont lamentablement
dérapé et s'étonne de cela que je vais
vous montrer pour le ranger ce litespeed
rescue adapté de la série envers power
rangers sauvetage est clair bon le jeu
et pas à moi en fait je les en protéger
les jamais rendu on peut dire je vais
voler ouais mais me regardez pas comme
ça parce que le coût d'un protêt des
jeux sans jamais les rendre on l'a tous
fait m
[Musique]
moi la seule série power rangers dont je
me souvienne c'était la première version
dans les années 93 à 96 bon alors je
vais pas détailler l'histoire des power
rangers s'est vu une série japonaise les
super sentai qui a été adapté pour
unique occidentale les scènes en costume
provient du japon celle avec des acteurs
ont été retournés au travail
concernant le jeu sur nintendo 64 il est
plus récent 1 puisqu'il est basé sur la
saison 9 de la série sauvetage est clair
et je sais pas vous pourrez qualité ce
jeu de blizzard d'étranges de
magnifiques
en tout cas qu'il fallait vraiment que
j'en parle elle est vraiment à se
regarder ça y est super méga zorn
vaisseau spatial robots géants flaque de
morne camion benne pour être les
passants les confitures des années à
fond je faisais une pause ici vous vous
attendez à quoi là maintenant des
megazord des pistolets lasers des armes
des enchaînements de coups au corps à
corps des bastons avec les mecs en même
temps et et vous êtes très très loin
abandonne tout espoir toi qui jouent à
ce jeu si vous imaginiez taper dans le
tas en faisant des mêlées de tarés avec
15 me en même temps vous pouvez oublier
vous ne pouvez tout simplement pas à
taper au corps à corps
z man show et vêtements chauds des pieds
aussi sept pieds show tient qu'aux
parents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sacrée différence
bon au début j'avoue j'ai eu une
réflexion machiste je me suis dit bon
voilà c'est power rangers jon c'est une
petite femme fragile c'est pour ça
qu'elle tire des petites étoiles
mignonne comme seule attaque et en fait
non ils sont tous pareils il quelque
chose des petites étoiles mignonne comme
seule attaque
c'est hallucinant je comprends pas on
achète un jeu pour voir encore ce
pourquoi pour la baston et et là on nous
sort mais c'est amy magique
[Musique]
change
ce qui au passage je suis évidemment
obligé de parler de nimation regardez
donc ce sportif celle que beauté du
geste cette fluidité de mouvement c'est
aussi beau que le médecin l'oeil aussi
parfait que le scénario de 2012 si
magnifique que la courbe sportifs à qui
on aurait greffé deux friteuse
électrique à la place des pieds dont
elle est sérieusement peut-être des
ennemis compenseront ça vous vous
souvenez de la flamme de mort de l'intro
et la cl votre ennemi votre mii d'une
femme de mon est votre objectif de power
rangers sauvetage est clair c'est de
nettoyer toutes les plaques de morts de
la ville en les aspergeant de petites
étoiles
oh [ __ ] la musique a changé elle va se
passer un truc là il ya un boss qui va
arriver moi je te le dis va se passer le
truc
des fois la musique change sans aucunes
raisons j'arrête inviolée va se passer
un truc concentre toi là il va se passer
un truc
pourquoi concernant la musique ensuite
je n'ai rien à dire la qualité est bonne
mais mon nez sur nintendo 64 donc c'est
normal qu'on retrouve une bonne qualité
sonore
[Musique]
hier j'ai nettoyé la ville je suis un
pur rangers déboires et claire
bon bah la suite te le vrai jeu va
commencer éteignez les incendies de
votre mère mais je me trompais le
cartouche ou quoi c'est quoi ce jeu
sérieux je veux jouer à power rangers -
20 juin carnac j'aurais su j'aurais
voulu notre jeu c'est cruel parce que
pour une voiture qu'on était en provoque
3 carambolage à les pêches ces voitures
qui brûlent on se trouve à strasbourg le
jour de l'an voilà j'ai nettoyé les
trottoirs j'ai éteint les poubelles en
feu et moi il commençait de jeu
maintenant ah ben voilà on fait quelque
chose qui ressemble à power rangers
super mais bien joli tube one by c'est
moche c'est construit verre transparent
ibla sérieux
[Applaudissements]
dieu que c'était nul
le meilleur moyen pour gagner c'est
d'appuyer comme un abruti sur la pelouse
du missile en fait c'est tout l'enjeu
qui était pour les [ __ ] d'abrutis vous
est perpétuellement en train d'appuyer
sur beaucoup d'autres à me regarder
[Musique]
j'ai été pompier éboueurs vous croyez
que maintenant je vais être power
rangers maintenant vous voilà bûcheron
j'ai vraiment vraiment du mal à y croire
la mission 4 consiste à utiliser le
ranger bleus pour détruire les souches
d'arbres sur le chemin je ne sais pas
quoi dire là franchement je ne sais pas
je veux pas comment vous décrire ça je
pense que nous venons d'entrer dans un
espace temps où la logique n'a plus
cours maintenant tout est possible
tiens voilà niveau suivant toujours pas
de power rangers je suis un but l'ancien
ça m'étonne même plus en fait ce jeu là
c'est une création qui ça aurait été
quelque part à mi chemin entre la
cocaïne et l'ecstasy l'âge de sauver des
gens mais quand je le roule dessus ça
fait une espèce d'explosion rouge du
coup je sais pas trop si je laisse au
bout si je les achève en fait quand on
scénario du jeu il est aussi profond
qu'un épisode de dora l'exploratrice en
gros ça ressemble à un ranger rouge soit
granger vers des rangers rouge se fait
capturer entre marange rp est donc
ranger verts repartent vers abuja rouge
feu c'était capturer rangers bleus se
ranger rouge quand jean rougeau conrad
gerber et ainsi de suite bref ces deux
et [ __ ] d'incompétents et c'est pas
les phases au megazord qui vont arranger
ça ou c'est beaucoup trop facile ou
c'est horriblement dur là quoi s'en
vient au fait qu'on ne puisse pas sera
fait ou en tout cas si on peut le j'ai
pas trouvé comment regarder celui là le
boss fait horriblement mal le problème
c'est que je peux pas faire deux pas de
côté alors je suis obligé de me
retourner pour fuir sans savoir si les
lois ou pas merci me touche encore une
fois chez moi
père sérieux quoi ça cette caméra en vue
fps est horrible tu fais quoi là ça sert
à rien ce que tu fais bougez relève toi
sort de la fille quelque chose c'est pas
bon c'est pas vrai j'arrête le massacre
de toute façon c'est pas la peine de
parler du reste du jeu tout le reste-
ressemble
[Musique]
bon un dernier jeu vite fait avant de
finir power rangers ce mighty morphine
sur mega cd bon alors comme tous les
jeux mega cd c'est pas vraiment un jeu
c'est plutôt une histoire interactive
vous regarder des extraits d'épisodes de
la saison 1 à 3 de power rangers et vous
devez appuyer au bon moment sur les
touches pour faire avancer l'histoire
bon c'est un américain d'accord mais
même si on fait rien du tout on a
presque l'impression de combattre et de
diriger le film
ce qui est idiot parce que vous ne
faites rien du tout en fait un vos
actions dont seulement aucune influence
sur le déroulement du hockey ce qui se
passe là ok j'y vais
il va détruire la ville
ringard has formation danoise
en innovant gloups
obama
un félin de californie a
les castors
[Musique]